in a small corner of the city of osmania
the sound of heavy machinery fills the
air
their metal Scoops moving Rubble as the
members of a rescue team searched the
concrete slabs looking for signs of life
then a call goes out
[Music]
All Quiet on the site and the frenzied
sound of digging swiftly ends
can you hear me tap on the side of the
wall
[Music]
but these desperate questions go
unanswered
there are hundreds of people here but it
is
silent
but they haven't heard anything
there's nothing
five apartment blocks occupied the area
the residents asleep when the earthquake
struck and it seems unlikely that anyone
survived
it looks like a lot of people lived here
foreign
not yet
Hope was fading and the Outlook bleak
we listened to the anguish tone of those
looking on
goodbye
yesterday the governor came here said
this woman but he does nothing there are
young children in these buildings but
they do nothing
a couple of hundred meters away near the
city's Central Square we found a similar
scene
another human tragedy
there was a man staring at a pile of
rubble he said he was waiting for his
brother the only thing he could do do
you think it's possible that your
brother is is still alive
up to 15 people are missing no one's
really sure
but this man knows his father is here he
just found his trousers
what have you found
is it possible that your father could
survive this
exam
s
the local highways are clogged
the supplies and the Specialists stuck
in traffic and many Regional roads are
now impossible
but they are desperately needed in this
city of debris
John Sparks Sky News in osmania